The gating values for each gate get
controlled by a tiny logistic
regression on the input parameters.
Each of them has its own
set of shared parameters.
And there's an additional hyperbolic
tension sprinkled in here
to keep the outputs between -1 and 1.
It looks complicated but
once you write down the math
It's literally five lines of code,
as you'll see in the assignment.
And it's well-behaved, continues,
and differentiable all the way,
which means we can optimize
those parameters very easily.
So why do LSTMs work?
Without going into too many details,
all these little gates help the model
keep its memory longer when it needs to,
and ignore things when it should.
As a result,
the optimization is much easier, and
the gradient vanishing, vanishes.